san diego california is one of the top
five vacation destinations in the u.s
and is home to the keating hotel which
lies in the heart of the city's buzzing
gaslamp quarter
want to say the desk this is christos
how may be of service
the hotel is the brainchild of local
property developer eddie kane everything
about the place is just the way he likes
it the keating was my vision i was at
the ferrari dealer looking at cars and
it kind of just hit me why not have the
ferrari of
hotels but this 35 room boutique hotel
is far from living up to guest
expectations
oh my gosh
eddie pitches this as the ferrari of
hotels but it feels like a hospital
sterile almost this is all style and no
substance i feel like it's a jail like i
don't want to take my shoes off ever
this is uh not exactly luxury
eddie had a sports car design company
and sank millions into the interior
design but he spent penis on things the
hotel really needs
let's not use this machine for the
sheets because it has rust in the back
making life a misery for his guests and
his staff
i have zero resources pretty much
everything there is to do here i do it
how glamorous is this
it's a hail operations here to be honest
eddie's constantly adding ideas he's
seen elsewhere but that's hurting the
hotel and the restaurant i believe our
menu is [ __ ] joke it's like four
pages long which are all favorites of
eddie's but we're not feeding a [ __ ]
million different eddies we're feeding
different people
at the end of the day i am the owner
right if there's something i want on the
menu jeff's gonna do it yeah i think i
pissed them
eddie will come in and say i want a
chicken parm slider on the menu i had
one in new york and i say yes i have
stopped being proud of my food
the hotel is millions of dollars in debt
and struggling to fill the rooms so i
have my work cut out for me if i'm gonna
get this place back on track we're
losing a lot of money
it's a nightmare but you should be able
to handle that eddie knows he's losing
money i just don't think he knows how to
fix it i don't have any hope that things
will get better
if anything works around here it's
because of pure dumb luck
[Music]
there it is they're keating
wow looks nice on the outside
beautiful
jesus is that a dog outside
hello how are you good how are you is
that a model dog was he real no she's
real what's her name
smudge
oh my god she's ugly
looks like a nightclub out there with
those ropes
hello how are you good to see you
there's a lot of red
wow i'm christos christos good to see
you um what do you do here lifestyle
concierge down here at the front desk
you gonna be advising me for my life are
you gonna be you need dinner so you
organize everything anything you need oh
now somebody likes red is that smudged
it likes red or no it's both the
designer and the owner wow wow
enjoy yourself right upstairs
we're on the second floor second floor
please perfect thank you
right here i like to always stop at the
car each floor is a different model car
who's obsessed with the supercars who is
that the owner emery so right here this
is your room
wow yes it's so empty more like a garage
in the guest room
and how much is this tonight 7.59
759
wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there
that is actually the jacuzzi tub in the
middle of the lounge it is in the middle
of lounge wow when they designed the
rooms they took away all the interior
walls but without sounding stupid these
are car designers correct they are car
designers now they're putting jacuzzis
in the middle of suites
last time i checked a living room was
for sitting in not taking a bath
how much do these things cost the
jacuzzi tub itself is about twenty
thousand dollars you don't take bath in
cars
this is crazy but who wanted all these
especially designs that is the owners
that's eddie that's eddie yes this is
crazy
oh [ __ ] the sports car inspired
furniture looks cheap and isn't even
functional it's different than anything
else um different from a nice hotel room
oh i don't know about that
who would want to sit here
and sort of watch the television and
watch the television
it works though
the sheets how can they also wrinkle
well have you slept in there why is that
we do them in-house when you say we what
do you mean you don't do laundry
lifestyle means everything your
mouthwash
it's like gas sockets all broken and
smashed down there and someone's left
their dirty ones there the plastic
plants that's outrageous 800
oh my gosh gordon doesn't like anything
about the hotel damn it
anything else if i have any lifestyle
needs i'll call thank you of course
so far i'm not impressed with the
keaton's pretentious and uncomfortable
design but maybe it can redeem itself
with the one thing every luxury hotel
should have impeccable room service i'm
starving
come on you're another desk this is
christos how may i be
what's a little bit bizarre for me is
i'm ordering room service at the front
desk there's no direct line down to the
kitchen there is no direct line down to
the kitchen the communication between
the apartments isn't really there so we
um take care of everything make sure it
happens listen i'm starving um i'll have
a tomato soup please and then pizza and
bbq chicken i'm fascinated to see the
chicken parmesan sliders i'll have one
of those i'll have that as soon as i can
bye-bye thank you bye
hello
hello how are you
thank you my pleasure wow
is this how it's normally served yes in
a to-go box yes
you pay 800 a night to stay here and
you've got to eat your food out of boxes
and plastic containers
are we short of soup because it's not
even half full
that's how they serve it that's that
that much yes
it's one cup
it's like a retirement home is that
luxury do you think no not at all
what would you rather do
sip that out of a cup
of course we barely got half a cup um
anyway and i'm digging if there's
anything else i can do for you just go
ahead and let it go okay brilliant
darling
i'm sorry
you can say that now
it's finished thank you my pleasure
a chicken parmesan slider
that's dreadful
[Music]
now i know why they got the boxes
it's a take-away puke box
pizza unappetizing in a box
especially when you're spending 800 a
night this place is obsessed with design
but serves room service in plastic
containers no wonder they can't fill the
rooms that is not my idea of luxury let
me tell you that's embarrassing
wow
[Music]
how can this place call itself a luxury
hotel i need to get some answers from
eddie the keating's owner and visionary
hey how are you how are you good to see
you
this place has
been your baby in many ways and i'm
dying to find out the vision the insight
and to why give us a little tour
i bought the building back in 2000 that
was around 6 million did you go to hotel
school
no you've never run a business before
not a hotel business now wow
so i was actually at the ferrari dealer
looking at cars and stuff and it kind of
hit me why not the ferrari of hotels i'm
more concerned what you were smoking at
the time than what you're thinking
why would you take one of the most
high-spec cars anywhere in the world and
turn it into a hotel
i don't know where he's coming from but
it does piss me off i designed the
keating to be the perfect hotel for me
not for him
where should i start
the floor it's all scuffed and marked we
have a resin floor it needs to be
updated i mean everything's just marked
to hell it feels cheap
um the sheets you can't call yourself a
luxury hotel if you don't have
beautifully pressed sheets okay what's
the idea behind sitting here so when you
have guests you know we can sit down and
talk but where's the sofa where's the
table where's the fun
do you know what hurt the most
i got soup served in a plastic bowl
there's a chicken parmesan slider that
tasted like it was cooked three days ago
who in the [ __ ] would put a chicken
parmesan slider together there's things
that don't go in sliders and chicken
palm is one of them that was my idea be
laughing as if it's funny and you think
because you own the place you can put
that in a roll and sell it
i don't know what he's talking about
this place is not bad so i think
gordon's comments were complete [ __ ]
you're trying to convince me this is
your idea of luxury
i don't know what to say when was last
time you stayed in the hotel it's been a
while you cannot stand there
and tell me that there's nothing wrong
with this place when you don't even stay
in it
you bought a building that was your
dream but it doesn't feel like a dream
experience to a guest nowhere [ __ ]
near it
i'm at the keating hotel in san diego
and i've just met eddie the owner who's
completely oblivious to the fact that
his supercar inspired hotel is seriously
underperforming
you're the owner you bought a building
that was your dream but it doesn't feel
like a dream experience to a guest
nowhere [ __ ] near it
i desperately want to help you
only if you start identifying the
problems
okay
could you send that young lady up to
clear that dog [ __ ] out there please
jesus
[Music]
trust me eddie is not used to honesty
like that right now he looks like a baby
that's just had his lollipop stolen
how are you who is this guy
first thing he does he lays right into
me
the room service was terrible
welcome to my world he opened the bed up
and the sheets were all like wrinkled
and most hotels have those giant iron in
things that the sheets go through there
we don't have that i tell eddie the
problems that we have but it may be
sometimes you tell people something and
it goes one side to another i was in
shock maybe gordon will get him to wake
up i don't know what to say that was
very embarrassing
[Music]
after my meeting with eddie i'm ready to
see how this so-called luxury hotel runs
on a normal night
hi there how are you guys how are you
are you a
luxury lifestyle
no i am actually sandra i'm the gm of
the hotel the general manager oh great
how long have you been here i've been
here for six years okay wow so you're
here from the beginning
i gotta have to tell you you got a lot
to tell me
yeah i bet she does because the keating
seems to have more complaints than guess
our room is not very clean
there's a hair in the cheeks as well
we turned out our bed and there's what
appears to be a bunch of sand the sand
what do you think of the red it's like a
brothel
you've been in a brothel i haven't it's
just whatever okay wow
i can confirm it is like a ruffle
[Laughter]
let me check on that right now we've
been waiting for 45 minutes
you know if it's not up in 10 minutes
just chancellor because we'll go to
dinner okay okay
how can they make a guest wait so long
for something that's not even cooked the
system for room service here is clearly
not working taking the orders at the
front desk then pass them to the kitchen
is madness i've never seen anything like
this before
let's go through the kitchen together
okay
weirdly the hotel's restaurant the merc
is in a separate building around the
corner can you believe that we're
waiting 45 minutes for cheese sport i
can't believe it but i'm not surprised
she looked pretty pissed off she did
look pretty pissed they sounded pissed
the three times they called as well
wow what is it is it cheeseburger yes
where's the [ __ ] cheese
is that it that is it how much is that
16.99 i believe you're kidding me
i can guarantee someone's going to
complain about that
hello how are you gordon yeah how are
you my name is aaron manager you're the
manager nice to meet you buddy um you're
the manager of the restaurant yes sir
that cheese portion there barely two
little slivers of cheese
they waited 45 minutes for us and it's
like no one gives a [ __ ] oh i definitely
do now that you've told me this is the
first time that i've heard of it why
would they wait 45 minutes for something
that's already i think the process
unfortunately is a little bit slow here
i think getting up the stairs is a
little bit of a challenge why don't you
take the call in the kitchen oh in the
kitchen itself we can't take that call
it's definitely an option but we've
always do you think that's faster i
think as the hotel takes it it's just as
fast so even though the customers are
unhappy with the weight that they've had
to endure you don't want to do anything
for them i didn't know how long the
customer was waiting until just now
wow okay manager [ __ ] me
aaron the restaurant manager isn't
taking any responsibility
if he worked for me he'd be long gone
how [ __ ] weird how'd you rate him out
of ten can we go into negatives aaron is
the king of excuses as far as being able
to kind of weasel his way out of things
but i'm not in charge of firing him
how are we doing over here guys no
wonder the hotel is half empty they
can't even get the basics like room
service and laundry right maybe sandra
the gm can tell me what the hell is
going on here right we're having a
chance to catch up thank you so all
these issues with the laundry where's
the laundry done
let me show you please
[Music]
oh here we are
so this is the laundry room wow
bloody hell you have got your work cut
out
these are domestic i know
these washing machines are designed for
small families not a 35 bedroom hotel
wow no wonder they struggle
your lifestyle concierge come in here
throughout their day to do laundry and
attend the front desk and take room
services
i mean this is crazy it is insane it is
insane i don't know how we do it
sometimes who presses the sheets oh we
don't we don't have equipment
so you don't press them please
can i show you where we are in the
pillowcases absolutely
you seem to know all these problems and
you're the general manager but if
there's one person who could stop this
it's you if the owner well yes i can
quit i can leave to another hotel and go
where everything is much better it is
hell to run this place you're a general
manager
you're managing nothing i spoke to the
owner i said this has to change
what's going on
gordon is totally right with what he's
saying but his eddie beat is so involved
in everything that's the problem i have
conversations with the owner what works
and what doesn't work in the restaurant
no matter how many times i say you know
what we should not have a book as a menu
eddie comes up with whatever he wants
but no one's taking responsibility
i pull back my duvet
and the sheets were shocking
eight hundred dollars a night
to stay in something pretty mediocre
you should be ashamed
i am ashamed i gotta get out of here let
me get down to the restaurants
[Music]
for a so-called luxury hotel the keating
has been a major disappointment it's
like gas the owner's misguided vision
you're trying to convince me this is
your idea of luxury it's taking its toll
on the staff it is hell to run this
place
hopefully the food in the hotel's
restaurant is better than it was in my
room how are you doing
table of one please
good evening
hey good evening how are you i'm very
well on yourself bro thank you i'm sorry
first time my name is david davis so
what do you do i am actually the
restaurant manager here
i thought i just met the restaurant the
little man i'm the other restaurant
manager
and the food how'd you rate the food out
of ten
six six
i wouldn't serve any of our dishes to my
dog
chef brian's kind of given up so much
has been taken out of brian's hands and
by eddie that i don't think that he has
the passion and the drive to be that
great anymore
starting off with chicken under a break
what does that actually mean
it means it's drier than a bone
amazing even the manager thinks the
food's terrible here and he's not
embarrassed to tell me
and then the kappa tattoo kevin tubby
yeah here we go with chicken uh sometime
tomatoes mushrooms
you like that one no oh [ __ ] really uh
i'm still gonna try it so for dessert
i'll go for the chocolate pig um it's a
10-inch dessert pizza
chocolate strawberries bacon
how can i resist that thank you very
much thank you
the table i'm ringing right now just
bring it as it comes okay everything's
under fire
right what do we have here this is the
brick chicken 21
21
brick chicken yeah it looks like
someone's just shot a brick
[Applause]
yeah i mean really dry that's actually
better than usual really yeah chicken
under a brick is where it should have
stayed because it should have never come
out of the kitchen
wow pardon my reaching okay this is the
cavitabian chicken okay
bland chicken's dry way too much
rosemary and just
as [ __ ]
at least i'd say room for dessert
what you have here is the chocolate pig
white and dark chocolate strawberries
bacon it's like we've had a crisis with
a toilet paper department someone's
wiped their ass with my dough
i mean it's just
i've never seen anything so [ __ ]
unappetizing as a dessert in all my life
absolutely
bacon and chocolate pizza o-m-f-g
yeah you didn't like any of it
not one thing [ __ ] mate
is the chef off tonight no he's in the
back he's in the back is he cooking or
no
so he's here but he's not cooking
hmm
i would uh really like to meet the uh
executive chef
chef
brian rutherford gordon ramsay
how are you
let's go somewhere out there
shall we
i'm lost for words i just yeah i don't
know i didn't know where to start um why
wouldn't you cook for me why wouldn't
you do that
it's not a question of me not cooking
for you it's do you want to see what
we're doing here in improvement because
i want this to improve you've been here
for how long five years five years
but you've been cooking for
30 years 33 years 33 years i didn't see
you on the line i didn't see you taste
anything
i didn't even see you inspire anybody
this position is killing me in my soul
i've just been doing everything that
eddie wanted
we have two large menu for the amount of
business we do
i have 120 items on the menu and we do
50 people a night how much of this
am i able to prep on a regular basis to
have
quality but you're the executive chef on
the menu yes i am how do you let that
food go out with your name above it
um you can't just give up and almost
you know abandon ship before it sunk
i'm at the end of my world you're toast
i'm tired
but you're you're an experienced guy
you okay
look at me look at me
are you okay
are you on medication yeah excuse me can
you get me some water please quickly can
you give me a chair please
a chair
jesus christ
call 9-1-1 please quickly 9-1-1 jesus
come here jesus christ urgently
what happened the chef's on the floor oh
[ __ ]
are you okay call 9-1-1 jesus christ
jeff just fell collapsed
can i have some water please and a cold
cloth
urgently let's try and stay alert
look at me look at me brian can you give
me a chair please
a chair
jesus christ
call 9-1-1 please quickly 9-1-1
jesus come here jesus christ oh my god
chef's on the floor
jesus christ
chef just felt collapsed just trying to
stay alert and drink some water
no job is worth this let me tell you
[Music]
i was with the gentleman we were just
standing talking unfortunately he just
flaps and banged his head on the back
here
i am really pissed off at gordon he's
stressing everybody out everyone seems
to be at their boiling point
has he been stressed out for long i mean
this put a lot of stress on all of us
but me being here yeah
but do not dare [ __ ] go anywhere near
that i put him in that ambulance
let me tell you something 150 items on a
[ __ ] menu the size of a [ __ ]
shoebox can send that man to an early
grave let me tell you
it's like he's a dead man walking yeah
and what he tried to tell me in a
five-minute conversation is that you've
over-burdened him because he does
whatever you want you pay salary but
you're not behind that line you have no
catering experience you haven't spent a
day in a kitchen i've never seen
anything so fragmented
it's like you're a little magpie a
little spoiled [ __ ] magpie that's
going around picking up little bits of
glitter and running back and getting
your army to expedite it for you
all that matters right now is that that
guy wakes up to mourn feeling better
enough is enough for one day yeah thank
you
for me the most important thing is that
he's okay but that guy has the world on
his shoulders and tonight proved that
what a day yesterday the good news is
that brian's out of hospital and they
said it was dehydration and anxiety so
i'm gonna shoot over to his house keep
the cameras outside and hopefully have a
chat with him
how are you sir come on in i'm so glad
to see you know that i'm telling you how
are you feeling i'm feeling well
we've got immense
troubles you cannot continue driving
yourself into the ground like that
eddie he takes advantage of my good
nature
do you feel well enough to come back to
the restaurant today yeah good let's get
you back in there and trust me this time
it's on your terms not eddies definitely
good to see you
the restaurant is the beating heart of
any good hotel so the keating has no
chance without chef brian thankfully
just a couple of hours after i saw him
brian is back at the hotel
after going to the hospital i believe
that gordon is totally
in my corner saying get back in there
get it you got this
guy it's time to get the whole staff
together to figure out how to get this
hotel back on track thank you all for
meet me am i happy to see you or what
how are you feeling more importantly i
am feeling very good brilliant welcome
back thank you
let's get everything out on the table
because life's too short festa i'm here
to help
and i just want to hear from you guys
what's wrong with the keating
the resources it's the resources i tell
eddie alex i'm eddie i can't do my job
your front reception desk should not be
doing laundry let me tell you that
the big concern i have is the
room service how on earth do we get
ourselves in that mess as a food
beverage manager yeah tell me why it's
going via the reception
it's determined by you know eddie oh my
god don't give me that
you're not the owner of the place
i tell you what i want and you guys need
to implement it
why is the menu so big
because eddie comes up with ideas i
eddie sees things eddie has a lot of
friends that come in that would like to
see more items on the menu yeah
if i go see something i like for
somewhere else i tell you guys to
implement it but you're not a chef he is
and he needs his identity and he needs
his voice
i do know brian doesn't like to say no
to me
you have a general manager you have a
head chef executive chef you have a
front desk manager you shouldn't get
involved and i give them ideas you know
because i have a vision here and i give
them the ideas no
no
i cannot work with you if you're like
this we have the key players there's one
little problem we have
and unfortunately it's you at this point
after last night's dramatic turn of
events
i finally found the courage to confront
eddie the owner now there's one question
i have to ask tell me who's the most
important person at the keating who is
it
eddie bryan yeah
the most important person at the keating
sandra who is it i i gotta say it's
eddie
yeah i mean i i believe it would be
eddie
eddie
sandra
no
no
the most important person at the keating
is the guest
and i think it's all been forgotten
about
and it's more about keeping you eddie
happy
we have to focus on the guests
i'm here to put this place right
understand that
eddie and sandra just come with me
if eddie won't listen to me and he won't
listen to his staff maybe he'll listen
to the people who could pay the bills
around here eddie up until now this
hotel has always been about you your
dream your vision now
it's about the guests
i want you to meet some very important
people i'm just really worried right now
i have no idea what gordon has in the
room
hello
how are you
i see uh guess that i've been staying at
the keating of the last 24 to 48 hours
oh no
when i see all those guests there i want
to run away right now i wanted to give
you a unique opportunity to
hear some very and i mean very valuable
feedback i've also stayed here
and i am frustrated but i'm here to get
this place back on the map give a little
insight please
what do you think of this luxury hotel
mad emoji i walked into the room and it
smelled horrible
there was the rest of the jacuzzi no
water
some of the features in the room were
just lower quality like the plastic
looked a little bit cheap and old so it
doesn't feel comfortable
i just feel like this place is design
kind of form over function
it was just kind of weird
where is one supposed to sit and eat
breakfast in their room
my husband had to stand up this morning
to have his breakfast while i took the
only chair and sat at the desk i'm sorry
our room service was um
we ordered a couple of the small pizzas
and they essentially looked like
microwave pizzas and then the order was
wrong so we called the cracks they
eventually you know brought up what we
actually ordered and then in the morning
they charged us for both wow i'm sorry
anybody else there was some really
high-end stuff and then at the same time
there was just simple amenities that
were skipped why are you saying there's
better at the same price out there
yeah eddie your baby your vision um on
the back of that feedback no i
appreciate the feedback
i have one question for you all
who would return here
let's do a show of hands who'd come back
to the keaton
wow
not one person
gordon's comment about it's not what i
want it's what the guests want wow i'm
starting to realize that some of the
things he's saying actually are true
i really apologize and i am looking
forward to having you guys in the future
i can tell you will have a different
experience
eddie and sandra you know i'm not trying
to embarrass you but this is for me
critical feedback and it's only gonna
get better
the feedback from the customers was good
i'm realizing there's more issues than i
thought we had and just being here over
the past couple days i'm seeing what
they are i think we can definitely fix
them and streamline them so the place
works a lot more efficiently and all the
guests are happy thank you i appreciate
it
eddie is starting to see how much things
have to change for this place to succeed
but for the hotel to have a fighting
chance of turning a profit i've got to
find a way to reignite chef bryan's love
of cooking let's show the gang what we
can do yeah i don't have much passion
here anymore i'm hoping that that gordon
being here will nurse it back um right
first was the roasted beet and burrara
salad
they've just been seasoned with a little
touch of salt pepper and then finished
in a little hazelnut vinaigrette
scallops
i like serving scallops with a nice sear
so a touch of salt pepper a little bit
of vinaigrette i've just made it sort of
citrusy cured sorry i love it when you
get excited like that it's energy coming
back i absolutely love it
why does that have a little taste
are you okay brian
you
you're killing me
there's two things on the plate the
scallops and the onion purees when i'm
on the line with gordon the energy level
just pops up and now i'm you know i'm
standing a little taller and
it's exciting
nice
happy
yeah good so nice to see you smiling you
know that
gordon kind of unlocked the chains that
i had allowed to be put on i'm with you
every step of the way but you need a
voice in here and your voice is on that
play let it scream
i love eddie but i have to be able to
just say this is not going to work this
is not to the benefit of the hotel the
guests the restaurant or anything you
can do it and i know you can do it i
needed this to
remember what i used to do and
that that there's no limit to what i can
do in the future
brian and eddie are both making great
strides and tonight my design team will
move in and try to get this hotel out of
the pits but first there's something
i've just got to try i've got a 25 gram
bath so i might as well use it
[Music]
it's been a challenging week at the
keating hotel
a place that was all style and no
substance but its owner eddie has
finally turned a corner good morning
morning
how are we good very good excellent it's
time to show him and his staff how my
design team have transformed the keating
into a place people will actually want
to stay okay guys let's be honest the
keating is a hotel with huge potential
right yes but you need to focus your
attention and energy to the guests that
are staying here
yeah
come with me let me show you the keating
let's go
come in
welcome
come here that is great
oh my god it's all opened up
wow there's no more dominant red read
carefully all those wonderful
configurations of your hands
welcome
to the kitty
it's just so beautiful isn't it it's
just such an emotional experience
you all have a hand in helping the
guests feel welcome
it's amazing are you disappointed the
red is gone no no no
it's a brand new warm inviting entrance
to a hotel
ready to see more yeah
nice nice nice
come into my suite
oh my god wow so much nice oh wow oh my
god oh my god
oh my god
i am definitely blown away
wow wow
welcome
to what i think is a sophisticated
comfortable
modern suite
yeah let's start off with that jacuzzi
if guests would like to take a bath all
the curtains they have a choice that's
how you embody
luxury the sofas
you can sit down you can watch tv three
meters away from the screen
brian you're gonna quiet on me again
jeez we thought we were sleek and cool
and now it's beautiful it feels
welcoming
come through the bedroom please
i really like the concept of the
made-over suite now it screams the
guests you get stuck in a perspective
sometimes
and you need to take a step back and
have someone you know come in and show
you and i think that's what lauren's
done it's amazing
now something really important i've
organized a free trial period from a
local leaning company use it to your
advantage that means the front desk team
doesn't need to waste time doing laundry
you've got more time to focus on the
guess
and sandra you are a gm
you're not a laundry assistant
the lifestyle concierge we don't have to
worry about laundry so i am happy
there's more let's go
right excited yes come through
we have refreshed the menu okay
wow
i've worked with chef bryan to devise a
short new menu that will play to his
strengths first impressions visually
it's very vibrant
the presentation is amazing and the good
news is two-thirds of the menu is gone
chef what do you think
i think that this allows me to speak to
the guest and erin i want you as a food
and beverage manager to take
responsibility of room service own it
and no plastic containers i think now we
have the proper execution the proper
understanding of the menu with limited
smaller items we definitely can execute
it a lot quicker and now i feel a lot
more comfortable and that for me
is great news because it means the front
desk is no longer looking after room
service or do laundry they can
concentrate on looking after the guests
yes
there's one more change we need to do
you've been wearing a red chef jacket
for far too long you deserve a white one
let me tell you
put that on thank you enjoy it
i certainly will i'm feeling great i'm
no longer eddie's chef in the red jacket
i'm the chef of the merc
bistro in white
it's not eddie's favorite color but it
is a proper chef's jacket you perform
like one you deserve it make it yours
thank you well done
this is the kind of energy you want to
see every day
so you know what as long as they're
doing their jobs i have no problem with
them saying no to me anymore big night
tonight it's gonna be a packed
restaurant you've got to remember you
are all team keating i know you can do
it oh absolutely absolutely
guests are arriving for the relaunch of
the keating hotel
and the first impressions are very
positive this is really nice you like it
oh yeah oh this is beautiful
at long last the front desk can focus on
welcoming guests how are you welcome i'm
cindy pleasure to meet you and the
hotel's new white lobby is a great
improvement
and before it looked like a bus station
now it looks like a hotel it looks much
more inviting
at the restaurant aaron is finally
stepping up
and taking a new hands-on approach to
room service
i'm not a plastic container in sight
[Music]
mr hanks right yeah excellent we got
room service already here for you
the simplified menu has brought brian
back to life i want the most gorgeous
plates in the world coming up in this
window
that's good news for the diners so
beautiful it's very tender it's like i
don't even need this knife this is a
joint where you don't need ketchup
because it's perfectly seasoned and for
the future of eddie and the keating
hotel keep it going
that's
if i had one thing to say to gordon
right now is just
thanks
all right ladies and gentlemen it's our
last ticket out
i've been really lost here and you've
woken me up
great job new day new day
and reminded me of who i am
place was all about eddie's dream of
what a hotel should be like
but if you've got the most important
person
the guest
i'm just hoping that eddie can trust his
staff and let them work as a team
because this is a place i'd love to come
back to
okay
right sandra you are a great general
manager don't stop being one okay
gordon
thank you
thank you so much i'm proud to be the
general manager of the keaton hotel
give me a hug
come on
well done seriously you can do the food
beverage you can handle the room service
easily and my god i mean you bounce back
from the dead let me tell you
literally literally make it yours okay
hold on and
do not change that jacket okay white
suits you you know that
and let your team run your business okay
i think this experience with gordon was
life-changing for everyone here what you
did to get the team back together i mean
i'm telling you no one could have done
but this place is on the road and good
luck i can't wait to come back it's one
of those experiences you'll never forget
good job guys sometimes you have to
trust me no no no no no no
you